you are arguing for the slaughter of
human beings because you're pro-choice
and I'm standing here in a strong word
it's like killing a fetus so it's not a
strong word it's really not and but
could I just finish my statement
[Music]
step forward if you agree with the
prompt
I have had unprotected sex
so I see we all been getting it off
the first time that I had sex I wasn't I
didn't have the knowledge that I I
should have I think I think
um just my I didn't know what plan B was
until I started having sex that just
like maybe I missed that day in class
but that was not taught in sex ed so I
didn't know what plan B was until
um I started having sex but now I'm a
lot more educated a lot more comfortable
like I'm on birth control
um but obviously like birth control
isn't always effective isn't always
accessible so I understand like my
privilege in that well the first time
that I had unprotected sex was a couple
months ago with my fiance we're both
adults and we were in a real period of
grief um because I had just had a
miscarriage I think about a month before
after we'd had protected sex
um the first time that I had unprotected
sex was unprotective unprotected sex was
with the person that I am currently
married to
um we got married straight out of high
school I was 18. it was like a week
after I graduated
and we're really happy together and we
loved the idea of having a child you
know currently pregnant right now
that's you know so clearly I had
unprotected sex to get here
are you going to college or are you do
you have a job like how is how's that
working um so I mainly do activism I try
to advocate for people who are in the
same position as the person inside of me
right now and I think that the value of
their life is intrinsic to every fetus
so honestly right now I'm just chilling
as an activist
but do you make money
sometimes if my followers give me some
sick depends when you were having
unprotected sex would you say that you
would have been financially stable
enough to have a child
no no
would you say you would have been
emotionally ready enough to have a child
no
okay
all right then I think I was in kind of
a similar situation to you
um not so much because
I was pressured by a partner or anything
like that but because
the sex ed courses that we had like
yours was lacking were very lacking in
terms of queer sexual education and the
sex I was having I thought I didn't need
any kind of protection for it because I
was sleeping with
people who couldn't get me pregnant the
first time I've ever had unprotected sex
I was young enough to not know what sex
even was so I was very much manipulated
and groomed by someone in my life to
think that what I was doing was okay and
normal
and that scared me because you know when
I finally told my parents
it wasn't a really good conversation
where they were like of course they were
shocked because that person is in our
family and they were like that isn't
real you're just trying to get for
attention kind of thing and then but in
a sense I knew that they believed me
because we went to some dingy ass
Walmart and bought a pregnancy test
because they were like if you were
pregnant you can't tell anyone that it's
his you have to say that we adopted
another child and you would have to keep
that baby I did not want to have a baby
at a very young age I was not
emotionally ready I was not financially
ready I was
still in school trying to think like I
have a future for myself that I want to
do you know
fortunately I was not pregnant do you
think that people can't achieve Bright
Futures when they have children they can
achieve Bright Futures if they have a
child I just knew that I wouldn't have
been able to achieve that future well
there are like resources available
particularly for people who are student
parents for people who are on campus
parents who have children babies
toddlers children of all ages there are
also resources in terms of crisis
pregnancy centers also known as
pregnancy help centers there's thousands
of them across the U.S there's five
crisis pregnancy centers for every
Planned Parenthood and so
I think that a lot of these resources
are not made known I think that a lot of
people kind of get into the situation of
being pregnant
um and nobody's telling them about these
resources and then they think that they
can't do it and then they get an
abortion that they might not have
actually wanted they felt like they had
to do you feel like that was your
situation do you feel like you didn't
want to have an abortion like if it
happened I think that
um because I grew up in a very
conservative home so abortion wasn't
even in the picture I wasn't even
allowed to have that idea and like
thinking of it now like yeah there are
crisis centers but we're also going
through like baby formula shortage like
there's not even paid parental leave so
if we're going to be able to bring a
child into this world I think we should
fight for more health care that is free
for women or people who can give birth
and especially since I was at a very
young age I honestly just didn't know
what I would do in that situation for me
when I started engaging in Intercourse I
started out using protection I've been
volunteering with Planned Parenthood
since I was about 15 when I was a junior
in high school I've had an intense
passion for Reproductive Rights so I
immediately as soon as I knew that that
resource was accessible to me I put
myself on birth control but
unfortunately birth control isn't the
end-all be-all and from putting myself
on several forms of birth control I
realized that the adverse effects of
birth control can be very very altering
and currently I'm in a very long-term
committed relationship with my boyfriend
and of course when you have someone
attractive you want to have sex with
them and he's the first person I've
really started participating in
unprotected sex with all right
yeah
I've not had sex yet and that's just
because of my religious ethical code and
moral code I've been I'm a Catholic I've
been raised in a Christian household and
I just don't see that as something
that's beneficial or valuable to my life
at this point there's been times when
I've questioned if I was ready and
questioned my faith but I've always just
kind of found my way back to the church
and agreeing with the church's teachings
so um
I've never really had a desire and I was
in foster care as a child and so I
witnessed a lot of sexual violence there
and it's just been one of those things I
almost feel like just subconsciously
I've never really wanted
um so I really don't see myself like
living in a sexual relationship with
another at this time in my life just
because it just isn't really what I feel
like is right for me sort of in the same
boat I'm Catholic as well but I'm not I
I haven't had sex before it's not just
because I I'm Catholic it's like either
other reasons as to why I haven't such
as para bonding and I think just it
helps to keep the marital acts within
marriage because news flash sex migs
baby so I think it's just good for a
child to have a mother and father
because when families are sort of
separated it causes a lot of problems
for children especially like with
divorce and I was like surveys have
shown that
and divorce is often worse than the
death of a parent just because it's just
like at least you know like when the
parents pass it's like they didn't leave
you behind so I have two questions for
you the first one is where did you get
those surveys from I don't remember I
was just an interest in passing but I
don't really know the second thing I
wanted to ask uh
you said something about sex always
making babies well you didn't say always
you said sex makes babies and I would
love to challenge that a little bit
because it's something it's not the only
reason for like sex is like you have the
pair bonding and sort of the emotional
uh going on between the two people but
sort of like the sort of the T loss the
primary purpose of it sort of is for
that but there's other legitimate sort
of secondary reasons absolutely yeah so
you would say that the primary purpose
of all sex is babies uh because I don't
say all sex because there's times where
you can't conceive because like the
woman cycles that she's not always
fertile which I think just was just the
natural order of that act is for having
children okay
I think what they were getting at is to
not assume that all sex is heterosexual
so yeah that is a pretty heteronormative
view I completely validate and respect
that you don't want to have sex for you
but uh for those of us who can't even
ever for any reason get pregnant during
sex I think it's a little reductive to
assume that that's like the reason
people would do it
I think there's also a difference
between reproductive sex and
non-reproductive sex
like let's be so for real there's so
many things you can do to not get
pregnant and still have sex with
somebody I'm obviously not Catholic but
I think that I think it's also important
to
um to remember that you know Catholics
and people who do believe that sex
should be within marriage um also
acknowledge that there's types of sex
like oral sex for example that you don't
conceive children by so I think maybe
not to put words in your mouth but maybe
what Luke is referring to specifically
is coitus and not other types of sex
because people can mean different things
by sex it's like um it's a very general
term hi this is ragni the director of
this episode please like this video if
you enjoy watching it and subscribe to
our Channel now let's get back to the
video
I have had an abortion
I had mine about a year and a half ago
um and I've never felt shame never felt
regret I've never even second guessed my
choice
um
surprisingly my parents are Middle
Eastern immigrants and they were like
very supportive the nine months of
pregnancy isn't
considered to be a challenge in its own
it's like oh you know you can give the
child up for adoption oh there are like
resources there are crisis pregnancy
centers but those nine months that's
still morning sickness that's still
doctor visits I had to go to the ER in
the very short time that it took me
finding out that I was pregnant to
getting the actual abortion because I
thought I had an ectopic pregnancy
because that's what my gynecologist told
me um there are so many things to
consider I can't go to school if I'm
sick if I'm already you know mental
health isn't something that's secure for
me and then on the top of that I'm going
to have to deal with thinking about this
pregnancy are people going to judge me
for being a Teen Mom
okay so I had an abortion fairly
recently I had one um
about three two to three days before my
recent birthday last year in November it
was a very unexpected
um event I remember having symptoms
almost immediately I was about six weeks
I believe five five weeks and seven days
I actually did not suspect I was
pregnant because I had been going
through some
um some traumatic life events that threw
my cycle off I'm my period was on
average 40 days late so I just didn't
suspect anything when I was six days
late that past cycle and my boyfriend
um who I was confiding in at the time
and telling about my my current uh
bodily Circumstances had a had a feeling
Beyond me the woman in this equation who
should know what's going on he was the
one that prompted me to go get a test
because he felt that I was pregnant and
when we found out it was a shock I'm the
type of person when in my relationships
I make very clear my positions on how I
am with you know abortion and pregnancy
and child rearing I I'm very transparent
in that matter because there there
should be no room for error in that case
but that's because I'm fortunate enough
to be educated in that manner I again I
was I'm a volunteer with Planned
Parenthood so I knew the resources
available to me and at that time when I
did conceive it was not when I was on
birth control and so
partially I I take responsibility for
the circumstances that led to the
conception of of that pregnancy although
I'm very grateful and I'm very
appreciative that I had access to this
form of health care it was something
that I grieved heavily it was something
that my boyfriend grieved heavily we
were not ecstatic to have done this we
were not happy that we had to make this
choice but because of our plans as
individuals as adults and our life plan
is to get married is to complete school
and to maximize our chances of being the
parents that we want to be I felt it
irresponsible to be selfish and say well
I want a baby and I don't want to make
that hard choice to terminate but when
you think of somebody else and that
would have been another individual you
have to think what's best for them if
they were to be born and I'm not in a
position to where I could emotionally
financially nor physically provide for a
child whereas if I would do the hard
thing now later on down the line when I
improve my circumstances I can be the
mother that I want to be instead of
disadvantaging myself and that person
who did not ask to be put in that
situation I
commend you for coming in front of like
a camera and saying that yeah uh my
parents don't even know either yeah I
don't either
I just want to say first of all thank
you for sharing those experiences with
us because I could hear in your voice
even though I couldn't see your face
it's difficult to share and I'm so sorry
that you had that period of grief and
those experiences
um thank you
I've miscarried twice
and taking the abortion pill I know
though it is a different process it's
not dissimilar in the function of it to
a miscarriage but you did say something
that I thought was interesting you said
you think it's selfish to bring a child
into a situation where you know that
maybe you're not economically stable or
you're not maybe in the best emotional
state to have a child
and my mother has five children and when
I was born my father was
leaving he was abusive
and we were on food stamps she was in
college she was waiting tables and
sweeping under chairs when she was in
labor with me so I want to sympathize
with that and say I know exactly that
kind of economic struggle that emotional
struggle that a lot of women are in
um
but I don't think it's fair to say that
people who are in poverty or people who
might have mental health or emotional
issues are selfish for being bringing
children into those situations because I
think that you can still have and love a
child in those situations and I don't
think that having children is something
that we should reserve for the wealthy
for the people who don't have mental
health issues I don't think it's selfish
for people who are not in those
positions of privilege to have children
for the rich for the white for those who
are in a position right so um I just
want to quickly respond to you and it
there's a reason why I included that in
my personal statement it's because
that's a personal belief that I ascribe
to myself I don't think generally that
it is selfish to bring children into
your circumstances I retract myself from
in in putting my personal beliefs onto
other people's experiences I only speak
from how I feel because I am I'm the
king of my own fate and in the same way
that your mother chose to have five
children I chose not to but I don't want
to ever take that away from anybody I
think if you feel like you have the
means and you have the willpower to be a
mother to be a father you do that but
that doesn't give you the right to
determine for other people that they
should also do the same well I think
that's kind of ironic personally because
I feel like that's exactly the point of
the question it's whenever a person
decides to have an abortion whenever a
doctor decides to perform an abortion
whenever a medical professional
prescribes an abortion pill they are
making a choice for that child in
pushing that onto The Unborn person then
then they are saying that The Unborn
person you don't deserve to live you
don't have the right to live you are not
rich enough to live you are not
privileged enough to live you are not
white enough to live what about the
woman though like that that that like
I've had this conversation with so many
pro-life people and it's always oh the
fetus the embryo this unborn life and
I'm like what about me but I was
actually going through it you can have
all these hypotheticals about you're
pushing this onto The Unborn life first
of all they never existed they are not
aware of their existence it's not a
hypothetical about what they could have
become or or
um you know you're not giving them the
right to life they never existed first
first of all they existed scientifically
scientifically an unborn fetus matches
all of the qualifications that NASA has
for a living individual organism
secondly I'd like to say what right does
anybody have to mitigate the outcomes of
their own mistakes by oppressing another
human being inside of them by using
unjust violence and excessive force
against a peaceful being inside what
about rape or incest I got pregnant from
rape four years ago I got pregnant from
rape I was raped for years years of my
life I have physical symptoms of that I
have reproductive issues as a result of
that but I think it's important to say
that babies like my daughter Rachel as I
talked about before and babies like my
daughter Mira who I got pregnant with
consensually are the same they're
they're
DNA wise there there's nothing different
in the DNA the human DNA between a baby
who's conceived in rape and a baby who's
conceived consensually so you're telling
women that they should be having their
children are you going to make that
decision for women that are raped just
because your experience you think that
it was ended up being a good idea for
you to have these children are you then
going to stand here and say that all
raped women should have their children
are you going to stand here and say that
children who are conceived in rape are
somehow different than children who are
conceived consensually no because I
don't see a difference why are you
bringing it up I would also say that
abortion is not evidence-based care for
rape victims there's no research that
shows that the outcomes of rape victims
getting an abortion is better than those
who do not so if we want to go purely
based off of Medical Science and
evidence-based care
no yeah I will suspect that we do have
statistical evidence that shows that
women who have access to abortion and in
societies where abortion is accessible
there is an overwhelming decrease in the
amount of abortions obtained and there's
also an increase in the economic
emotional and physical advancements of
the people who have access to that care
and I will
um acknowledge because I do think that
what was inside of me what was inside of
you what was inside of you I I
personally believe it is a life
um it is I mean I held mine in my hands
but to equate that to me
um and an already birth human being this
this thing I have a photo of it in my
phone I was going to bring my ultrasound
as well but I thought that would be
triggering for some people but what I
possessed in my hands when I took it out
of my pants when I expelled it from my
body is I think it is ludicrous to
equate that to me there was no head
there was no arms there was no legs
there was nothing there how far along
were you I was five weeks and seven days
you were five weeks and seven days yes
and I um you know that at five weeks a
baby has a heartbeat that does not first
of all that does not it has a
two-chambered heart no heart cells can
beat in a Petri dish if you remove it
heart cells it's it's electrical
impulses but I mean when we talk about
life and this is my personal um opinion
I don't think
um when you draw the conclusion of what
is life I don't think that is a legal
question I think that is a moral and
philosophical argument and when you try
and establish what is life I mean there
are plenty of instances where we
acknowledge that there is life and yet
we make decisions for them when people
are brain dead we acknowledge that there
is life there and yet they are dead I
feel like when you try and say well this
is life so therefore it is deserving of
Rights we extend more rights to someone
who is hooked up to a machine keeping
them breathing without any conscious
experience and we extend to them more
Humanity than a woman and her body and
my argument is simply bodily autonomy I
think in no circumstance shall we force
somebody should this State I should say
should the government compel somebody to
use their body against their will even
if they are personally responsible for
the individuals the reason why even if
you have a child and that child needs
you for bone marrow or blood
transfusions the state cannot compel you
and hook you up to a machine against
your will to force you to keep that
individual alive and I think and when we
live in a democracy and we prioritize
human rights you have to put bodily
autonomy above and preserve it
regardless even if you were a drunk
driver and your irresponsible illegal
actions led to the the harm of another
person the state cannot put you in a
position where your body must be used as
a resource against your will I think it
is a violation okay first what you would
like firstly I ask you about
evidence-based care involving rape
victims okay uh not economic outcomes
after a rant I wasn't arguing off the
ring well yeah well as I said you said
yes we do have statistics and then you
wrote statistics that had nothing to do
with what I said
um I would also like to say that the
whole bottle of autonomy argument it
doesn't hold up pregnancy is ordinary
and healthy care 99 of the time we have
not comparable to hooking you up to a
random person your Offspring is your
child they are genetically and
emotionally related to you from the
moment they are inside of you my baby is
literally grimacing right now inside of
me they can make squint faces so it's
it's not even comparable the
relationship between a child and the
relationship between a rando but you
don't do nothing you do not use it you
do not you do not you do not get to
mitigate the outcomes of your choices by
violently ending the life of another
human being that you are responsible for
bringing interdependency even if I even
if I invited someone into my own home a
friend a family member I have the means
if I choose if I tell them I do not want
you there by my own choices I allowed
that person into my home into my space
into my domain and then I change my mind
and I rescind my consent we have the
ability it's called self-defense and I'm
nowhere near argue viewing that
pregnancy let me clarify now before you
jump to conclusions about what I'm
saying we have no no issue with and
again I'm not saying that pregnancy is
the same as self-defense but in those
arguments even when you put yourself and
you put another person to a state of
dependency when you invite them into
your home you have the means to remove
them and I think when it comes to your
body and and I'm just arguing in terms
of the state because there's a lot of
things that I disagree with in terms of
like people smoking cigarettes because
we have evidence that shows secondhand
smoke kills you can kill somebody from
the means of you having an addiction to
cigarettes but should we punish that
person for the choice that they made
simply because I ask something what
about the child inside of you there was
what I passed in my hands was not a
child and I think it is very
disingenuous to say what I held in my
hand is that you is the you it's any of
you it just wasn't what was it an embryo
what is it a number of cells well number
is just a term
is the egg unfertilized is that a human
being no because fertilization
I want to hear what you guys have to say
so an egg is distinct from an embryo
because an embryo is a genetically
distinct whole organism it's not merely
just a part like a skin cells egg sperm
because we can tell that because a few
words apply the net test so like any
amount of nutrition any environment or
any amount of time like an embryo will
develop into a mature member of a
species but sperm eggs skin cells tumors
they're not going to develop into it
right whole organisms so it's not the
same thing oh yeah of course I do I I
absolutely agree I think an embryo is a
stage of development but I don't think
you afford that stages of development
the same human rights that you would a
full-grown human being it's the reason
why we make a distinction between
children and adults a child can develop
into an adult do we automatically
ascribe them you can drink you can vote
well they're not they are not that yet
and why make that distinction but then
how does that give us the authority to
kill the child I'm not saying give you
the authority to kill a child but I
think if that the the argument that I'm
making is I feel like there is a
fundamental difference between something
being attached to you reliant on your
resources and something being dependent
on you for other types of resources
beyond your physical body it's the
reason why I'm making um a reference to
um blood transfusions and organ um
donations because that is directly
attributing what your body needs to
survive to give to somebody else to help
them live as opposed to a child that is
already born that simply needs your
labor and financial resources to keep
them alive and support their already
existence in living on their own but
when we're talking about the value of
human life I don't think it's at all
fair to say that an unborn child is
worth more than their mother or who
would be their mother I don't think it's
fair to say that the mother's needs and
her state of life or their state of life
don't
matter in that situation because they do
and
it's not this like
killing a fetus for fun nobody wants to
do that nobody wants to be in that
situation or to have an abortion but
like you can't just act like we always
should be prioritizing this what isn't
even a child yet but none of us are
saying we're prioritizing the child over
the mother yes you are yes what happens
during pregnancy what happens during
pregnancy the mother is new uh trying to
think of the words
the mother is giving life to the fetus
the mother is supporting the fetus's
life as it grows and so what we're
saying is that the child and the mother
should be equally supported are they
through the pregnancy
so supporting the financial needs of a
mother is a need that can be handled
through non-violent means whereas you
guys are advocating for violent means to
end the life of a person it is violent
to rip suction starve uh it is violent
to take limbs off of people it is
violent to induce a heart attack yeah
and you start you starved your embryo
that's what happened that's how the pill
works you probably do that in Labs
somewhere
else but it's a human being I feel like
we we keep getting away from the facts
that life begins at conception it's a
human Embrace science does not say that
the Bible says
it feels like the conversation is not
going any
where
don't get a brunch approach oysters and
pro-lifers together I'd rather abort a
child than put them through the foster
care system
and this is like I didn't consider this
until I myself was put into that
situation where
it's not just get pregnant put the kid
in the Foster system it's that again
like I said nine months of pregnancy
um and
I would not go through those nine months
of pregnancy even though I if I had the
option of
um giving my kid up to the foster care
system
um like
you have to still go through those nine
months of pregnancy it's not just you
can just drop it off
so I feel like first before we get into
this conversation we need to establish
how foster care Works someone who is in
the system I understand how the system
works is someone whose parents are we're
foster parents I understand the system
is not something you can willingly just
register your child for not like the
adoption system foster care is a system
of the government to protect children
who are in unsafe environments that they
see the child as being in an unsafe
environment my mother was a drug addict
she we were living in government housing
we were homeless multiple times my
mother was severely addicted to alcohol
just not at a time in her place where
she could really have a family but she
did have a family and so my grandmother
came and watched us and my grandmother
over time just really was convicted
because she was about Christian woman of
the reality that this is no environment
for a child to grow up in and she wanted
to do something if anything to help us
have a better life and she knew
financially she could not take us in but
she wanted to do something so she called
CPS and CPS came and took me and my
siblings away now did I have the best
experience at foster care absolutely not
I still live today with bruises and
sores on my body from foster care and I
was in there up until I was 19 months
old I was a baby but it still affects me
to this day and I
you know I I really I really struggle
when I hear people say that like you
know a child in foster care is somehow
less valuable because of the way the
government treats children in foster
care because I just don't think that's a
correct opinion to have to treat a child
as valuable as dehumanizing and I'll
know about the rest of you but I'm one
thousand percent against dehumanization
of any human being whatsoever I don't
think anyone is saying that foster care
kids are less valuable though
like you didn't mean that did you no
nobody's saying that I just wanted to
make that clear do you have a uterus I
do not have a you do not have a uterus
so I'm not saying that your opinion is
invalid or that you should not be
included in this discussion but I'm
saying that that's important to keep in
mind is that you could never be in this
position of having to decide whether you
in your body want to keep and raise a
child from your body you are arguing for
uh the slaughter of human beings because
you're pro-choice and I'm standing here
in uh where strong where a fetus cannot
so it's not a strong word it's really
not and but could I just finish my
statement we're standing here in defense
of the children because they do not get
that voice because they do not have that
voice because they are in the womb so
then are you going to adopt it assuming
you well right that's not an argument
you can make because I am currently not
in the financial place oh
to adopt but it is a choice that I could
make to become a foster parent the issue
is is that becoming a foster parent is
something that you register with the
state it's something it's not as easy as
just saying like well you you know you
can just one day become a foster parent
it is a long test part that's expensive
there's tons of things that go into it
yeah I would also say thousands of
dollars they also you guys had something
to say talking about like who should
have a voice in this discussion but it's
like The Unborn don't have a voice
they're not yet able to like have a
voice but they are still human beings
with dignity and we ought to respect
that so I think it's like I think we
really need to sort of figure out like
what are we talking about here because
if abortion doesn't kill human beings
then no justification is necessary
however if it does kill human beings no
justification is adequate I always say
that if murder was happening at the rate
that abortions happen at it would be
Armageddon like it is just absolutely
women I think it's like a quarter of
women will have an abortion in their
lifetime
if that was happening if an eighth of
the population was being murdered
then it would be the purge why do you
think we're so distraught though it
doesn't affect you though like but it
doesn't affect us
Injustice anywhere is a threat to
Justice everywhere but why is every
single person even if they are not under
my jurisdiction the oppression of that
person is my business
this is to us it sort of sounds like if
we're saying it's like if you don't want
an abortion so you just don't have one
but as we hear it sort of the same way
it's like if you like don't like slavery
don't have a slave we sort of hear it
sort of in the same ways because it's
involving like sort of the destruction
of the Dignity of a human person like
abortion and slavery violate the Dignity
of you so you're comparing abortions
I actually agree with that and I think
that ties in nicely to this
systems and Foster Care argument because
argued vehemently at the time in which
we were about to end slavery that we
should not end slavery because we don't
have the systems we don't have the
systems ready for all of the slaves that
will now be free there's no jobs out
there for them they don't have any land
oh we need to keep them as slaves until
we have the right system no you don't
get to degrade the Dignity of another
human being until you're ready for them
to be here
today until you're the ready until you
are ready for them to live dignified
lives that's unjust I want to touch on
the prompt about the foster care system
and I just wanted to emphasize that for
me I didn't
take into consideration the foster care
I don't feel like anybody is less than I
don't think that you're less than I
think me and you are entitled to the
same rights of course um just personally
when I made my decision it wasn't a
matter of I don't want my child to go to
the foster care be adopted out it wasn't
that wasn't the question
um what I took into consideration what
my boyfriend and I decided together was
we did not want to put me through the
physical constraints of pregnancy
without him because my boyfriend he is a
traditional very traditional Christian
and I um I'm no longer a religious I
grew up in the Catholic church and I I'm
not religious anymore but I respect his
views and he carries a lot of views that
you have but because of his
consideration to me and his approach to
the family structure
he knew that he was not in a position to
take care of me in that vulnerable time
in the the weeks that I was pregnant it
was very extremely hard for me it was
mentally and physically draining um the
changes that were going on it was to the
point where I could not uh participate
in the daily activities that one does go
to work feed themselves get out of bed
it was very psychologically difficult in
that short period of time and we knew at
that point that it was going to be a
very demanding and laborious pregnancy
had I gone through with it but because
of how he feels and his responsibility
and his duties that he places on himself
as a man he wanted to make sure that
that experience of pregnancy and when we
do decide to have a child I'm in a point
where I can be cared for appropriately
just the way I waited out and again it
wasn't because I you know this aversion
to the foster care in fact I feel like
we should better resources for those
children because they have every right
to be here I'm more so focused on
whether or not again should the
government
enforce and place themselves in such a
personal matter when it's a matter of
people using their bodies I would think
most of us in some regard agree with you
um I can't speak for everyone here I
don't know everyone's like various
political beliefs yeah most of us would
agree with you and that's why we're
pro-life is because we see it as that's
what the government is doing to children
in the womb the reality that the
government could have just that because
of the way that the government works and
because of the way that the abortion
system works the reality I just could be
non-existent and not exist at all is
horrifying and the reality that my
memory my life my my genetic makeup the
people that fought for years to give me
rights that can all just be a race is
horrifying but it would have never
happened it's not like it happened and
then like it was a race like it's
conceived my mother had the option to
abort yeah therefore it could have
happened parents should be informed if
their teen is seeking an abortion
foreign
so when I was being sexually abused my
parents didn't know when my rapist found
out
um that I had a pregnancy scare he was
like I will [__] kill you if if this
is the situation I'll kill you
um and I think that if I had gone into
an abortion facility as many girls and
women have and been forced by my rapist
to have an abortion I think that this is
another another I guess part of a system
where mandatory reporting fails is it
has many times in abortion facilities
particularly in Planned Parenthood
parents need to be informed if their
child's being sexually abused and
because mandatory reporting often fails
in this way because Planned Parenthood
is a business and they make money off of
what they do I think that it's really
important for the parents at least to to
have this knowledge and have this
understanding
yeah I think it's a really kind of
tricky situation and topic to discuss
just because there are so many like
there's such a breadth of situations
that can occur and have occurred and I'm
so sorry for what you went through by
the way but like that situation is
really awful and it definitely
highlights how
um having parental oversight is good and
important in certain situations but also
like
there are situations where young people
are in situations with abusive
households abusive parents who if they
found out that that teenager that child
was attempting to do something to care
for themselves and to help themselves
live the life that they need to or for
their health or whatever reason they
might have for doing it they'll be
prevented from seeking care of any kind
not even just like
an abortion they'll be prevented from
seeking any kind of sexual illness Care
Health Care of any sort because their
parent is aware that they were looking
for that kind of support and I'd like to
go off of what you're saying I agree
full-heartedly that there are different
situations where it could be dangerous
for the individual to tell their parents
and that's why I think Pregnancy
Resource Centers which is what we
support are such a a valuable tool
because they have the right to put
protections over this young individual
or older individual and if they are in
an unsafe situation they house them they
feed them they get them a job away from
the area where they are you know they do
stuff to help but also those situations
and the situation the child was conceded
at child size value so that's why I'm a
firm believer in protecting both the
mother and the child I mean I I would
also like to say that like as much as
young people don't like to hear it and
as much as I didn't like to hear it
myself because I had you know a messed
up house told because I had a parent who
was not
um who was not a safe parent I think
that parents have rights uniquely like
the Ohio Initiative for choice right now
is trying to attack parents rights
trying to make it so that people can get
medical procedures or supposed medical
procedures in abortions and not have to
notify their parents there have been
teenagers and young women who have died
from abortion procedures we we have
people that go and counsel outside of
planned parenthoods and abortion
facilities and we've seen like we've
documented reported to the state
suspicious behavior of people bringing
busloads of minors in to have abortions
and you know it's one of those things
that we just have to look at the reality
and we have to address it there's
actually statistics that say that the
majority of women who have undergone sex
trafficking report having more than one
forced abortion specifically saying
forced abortion and we are against that
too right we are against people being
forced into portions as much as anything
else I think parents have an obligation
to care for the child that they have in
their care and I think it is a parent's
responsibility to support that child of
course but then again I feel like I'm
speaking from a privilege of where
um I I obtained mine when I was already
a legal adult so I didn't have to tell
my parents I just know for me personally
because I went to Planned Parenthood to
obtain my abortion and even when I
obtained my birth control and my routine
screenings from them some of the
questions that they always ask me was
are you safe are you in a safe situation
are you doing this because you consented
to it when I obtained my abortion they
asked me is someone forcing you and they
have signs all over in the clinic
telling them or telling patients that
they are obligated to report if you are
being sex trafficked or abused in some
way
um the reason I disagreed was because I
believe the prompt said teens uh should
have to come to their parents
um I am acquainted with someone who just
had an abortion who is the same age as
us and she did not tell her parents she
has yet to tell her parents well I think
we're talking about telling parents
before the procedure particularly
because that that has ramifications I
mean I'm sure afterwards there's some
ramifications but I think parents like I
said would have the right to know before
you get the procedure I have a question
um because I think a lot of us are
coming from the approach of like minors
but I'm saying and specifically with my
case because I was already legally an
adult when I had my
um do you feel like even in cases
although we are teens here I'm still
legally an adult should my medical
information now that I am legally able
to obtain Care on my own because that's
where I'm going to operate from should
even against my wishes should they be
informed because I think for me with
such a sensitive topic I want to go to
them when I'm ready because I'm coming
here now sharing my story but I was not
prepared to come out with mine because
it's still something that I agree with
to this day still something that my
boyfriend and I we still tackle with
every day but I just don't agree with
the idea that even though I'm a teenager
I'm still an adult and I should still
have my my choice to not expose my
private medical information to my parent
if now that I'm willing and able to make
that choice that should be violated I
think that we would all agree that like
for an adult you know no if you're a
legal adult you shouldn't have to tell
your parents however I think we're
specifically talking about minors okay
okay
not possible I think it's possible I
think there's fun I think there's some
ways to find some middle grounds yeah I
think we already have here today unlike
certain parts of it but that's on parts
of it not on the abortion issue itself
thank you guys for your time and your
vulnerabilities
appreciate hearing new experiences
thanks for sharing your stories no
matter what
she's like I'm ready to go
okay